i always want more parmesan but i'm
embarrassed am i the only one on the
desk that loves this song
i'm the parmesan cheese guy
[Music]
we get it we get you know why he gave
the people what they want cheese i agree
and also it's like it's like the
greatest ear worm
ever written in a way because it is so
weird and catchy but it's so catchy we
all understand it because we all want
more cheese
you all know what i'm talking about i
mean it became a huge hit on tech talk
and on social media and everywhere so
i don't know like
even i asked simon's son i'm like what
was your favorite act and he's like well
the parmesan cheese guy and i'm like see
simon your son knows what's up
and that's only an act that can happen
here on america's got towns exactly
right because it's a variety show so i
think that's what makes it so fun or you
know the same with the football players
you know players choirs you know singing
that fun song you know it was like a
song written for the trolls movie and
they're like out there seeing that
because they're all the words
cute they were cute as much as the
talent i also love to see what you are
going to wear for the live shows so when
you and sophia come out and you're both
wearing pink your reaction is
what are you wearing sofia vergara are
you wearing pink
no i love that we're both in pink
because we know what's up because pink
is the color of the moment
and so i love
sharing the pinkness with my fellow
judge so much pretty i swear um okay so
obviously we can't have summer without
america's got talent uh but i love
because you always come refreshed from
vacation how was your vacation can you
tell
usually i'm sprayed to tan but this is
but this is my real tan
yeah i i'm still one of those you know
old people that actually lay in the sun
i know that a lot of people now don't
lay in the sun anymore
but i i don't know i love to live and
part of that for me is right now in the
sun yeah i don't think too much about
like i don't know 20 30 years down the
road you know enjoy the race sunscreen
well you celebrated your third wedding
anniversary on this vacation i mean
what's it like going into this third
season of married life amazing yeah yeah
i mean i feel like we've been together
for 10 years
but in a good way you know i love him so
much we have the best time together and
yeah it's it's just flying by yeah and
real quick olivia newton john i know you
posted about losing her what did she
mean to you and how do you hope she'd be
remembered in such a light you know
she's such a such a light always like
look up to her
amazing singer dancer performer just
like this lovable
person this light this beauty and you
know but she's done so many amazing
movies so she will always be with us in
many generations to come
[Music]